this morning we have a new look at a
48-hour story a dallas man murdered just
outside his home 18 months ago jamie
faith and his wife were taking their dog
for an early morning walk when he was
gunned down
48 hours correspondent peter vanzant
reports on the digital records that help
investigators solve the case
on october 9 2020 jamie faith was shot
seven times as he walked his dog
the murder seemed random but
investigators soon found texts that led
them to the shooter
the reality is today in our world it's
really difficult to get away with a
murder
jim holland a retired texas ranger and
cbs news consultant says jamie's wife
jennifer forgot to delete texts that
mentioned an old boyfriend
darren lopez was a high school
sweetheart of jennifer faith and he
wanted her back
when law enforcement finds out there
they're going to dig into their cell
phone records text messages so
the technology that's such a part of our
lives
so long as you're living a lawful life
it's great but if you're doing something
shady you're going to get caught because
you're leaving an electronic trail right
obviously you know everyone in society
loves you know all the great things that
we have the text messaging and
everything else that goes with it
instant communication but the reality is
is these are footprints
he's traveling from his residence to the
faith's home in dallas texas
and we know that because of electronics
because of purchases because of
surveillance camera footage
daryn lopez was arrested and charged
with jamie faith's murder he pleaded not
guilty while he admitted killing him he
claims it was jennifer faith's idea you
can see peter vanzant's full report
tonight at eight eastern seven central
on the cbs streaming network